[Musique]
le week end a une nouvelle fois une
nouvelle fois été riche en actualités
sportives dans les yvelines a pour nous
présenter ses principaux résultats des
yvelinois c'est une habitude désormais
le lundi dans le journal ni quel ennemi
d' eurobonds soir en soie gris je suis
ravi comme à chaque fois de vous
retrouver le lundi mois est également
alors vous êtes le journaliste au sport
de cette rédaction michael ont joué
notamment le 3e tour de la coupe de
france de football ce week-end
oui grigorian répète chaque année la
coupe de france fait rêver tous les
footballeurs français cette compétition
permet de voir des scénarios
rocambolesques ce week-end la magie
opérait du côté de monti le bretonneux
lésigny mon teint qui évolue en deuxième
division de district ont réussi à
renverser la montagne choisy le roi et
l'équipe 2 r2 trois divisions au-dessus
le score 0 à 0 et sans tirs au but à 3
pour montigny le bretonneux
on écoute les réactions micro de notre
journaliste marylène et y est affiché
on est hyper content franchement j'ai
pas trop les mots parce que ça prendra
pas je visite de cette façon là et a du
coup à très heureux très heureux parce
qu'on retient c'est heureux
on a été solidaire et ça ça le foot on
avait quand même l'objectif de se
qualifier on savait que ça serait se
serait pas facile mais au moins on
voulait on ne voulait pas juif juge ce
match on voulait chercher à se qualifier
voilà les joueurs ont fait les efforts
nécessaires ils ont été courageux et
solidaires pour pouvoir aller au bout
encore un grand bravo à montigny le
bretonneux tour d'horizon à présent des
principaux résultats de ce troisième
tour de coupe de france ce verset qui
évolue en n3 n'a eu aucun mal à
s'extirper du piège tendu par le club
d'ormesson l'équipe de d2
score final 6 à 0 de son côté le china a
failli réaliser l'exploit contre bagneux
mais s'incline 3-2 c'est terminé
également pour bois d'arcy bailly noisy
deux équipes de d2 enfin l' aventure
continue pour vélizy qui s'impose face à
admirer voisins le bretonneux qui domine
c'est 1 à 0
au total il y aura 14 club des yvelines
au quatrième tour rendez vous le
dimanche 30 septembre prochain
mais bravo à tous nos yvelinois alors il
y avait eu aussi du handball ce week end
michael vous êtes incollables un grégory
sur l'actualité s'est saisie pour sa
première apparition de la saison dans le
championnat de nationale 3 plaisir s'est
imposé de justesse sur le tas de
montfermeil sur le score de 25 à 24
en quête d'une montée cette saison les
plaisirs oies se retrouve 4e après cette
victoire pour tenter de prolonger cette
bonne dynamique plaisir tentera de
remporter sa deuxième victoire samedi
soir prochain sur le terrain de saint
michel sport en termine par du basket
est ce que vous aimez les festival
offensif grégory wimbée plus tôt alors
c'est le gros score du week-end dans les
yvelines le club de le fc trappes neuf
et n'a pas fait de détail ce week-end
dans le championnat de nationale 3 les
trappistes ont pleinement réussi leur
entrée en lice en s'imposant regardez
bien le score grégory à 112 à 53 sur
leur terrain contre séguinière à saint
louis basket une véritable démonstration
résultat qui permet évidemment au
trappistes de prendre déjà la tête du
championnat
merci michael pour ce tour d'horizon est
encore plus de résultats sportifs à
suivre on vous retrouve dans quelques
instants pour votre émission est aux
manettes du 7-8 sport c'est tout à
l'heure dans sur cette chaîne tv 78